[MUSIC PLAYING]
Installing a pool above
ground costs much less
than installing one in-ground.
This is because there's
no excavation required.
You can build an elevated
deck around the top
to give it an
in-ground appearance,
or you can simply climb up
a ladder and jump right in.
No hole to dig, no
underground pipes to install.
Just a day or so of
on-site prep and assembly,
and you can take to your
above-ground pool like a duck
to water.
At the factory, a
computer-guided machine
cuts vinyl panels for the pool's
water retaining inside surface.
The vinyl comes in a wide
choice of printed designs.
It's tear resistant, UV
resistant, and is treated
with an antifungal coating.
The wall panel is rectangular,
and the floor panels are curved
to fit the pool's perimeter.
The wall panels go
through a welder that
fuses a bead to the top edge.
A bead is a flexible
U-shaped thermoplastic strip
that is used to attach the
pool wall to the liner.
A hot welding tool slightly
melts both the bead
and the liner edge, so when
they cool and solidify,
they're bonded.
The liner is ready
to be assembled.
Workers use a manual welding
machine that generates
heat with radio frequencies.
They overlap the edges
of adjoining panels,
then fuse them together.
After connecting the floor
panels to each other,
workers complete the liner by
joining the wall to the floor.
A quality control inspector
checks every soldered seam
to make sure they're solid.
Meanwhile, workers
manufacture the pool's
structural components.
They feed a continuous strip
of painted galvanized steel
through a roll former.
The strip is shaped
to a specific profile.
A punch press cuts
the components to
the required length and shape.
Four different structural
components are made this way.
The pieces that form
the top and bottom
tracks of the pool, the
vertical posts that support
the pool wall, and
the ledges running
along the top of the wall.
The wall is also made of
painted galvanized steel.
A roller impresses a corrugated
pattern to give the wall
more vertical strength.
Then, a press punches out
openings for the pool's
water inlet and filter.
After folding each end
of the wall over itself
to form a strong edge, they
punch holes for the bolts
that will join the edges.
A stamping die
progressively shapes strips
of galvanized steel
into connectors.
The connectors join the vertical
posts to the structure's
bottom track and top rail.
An injection molder makes
the plastic covers that will
hide those connectors.
Workers then box the liner
and structural components
for transport to the
installation site.
On site, they lay crushed
stone around the perimeter
to support the bottom track
under the weight of the water.
Next, they unroll the
pool wall and place it
in the bottom track.
They place a vertical post
over each bottom connector
and secure it with screws.
Inside the pool wall, they
lay down a base of sand
and compact it.
Then, they lay down
landscaping fabric.
They cut a hole for a
central bottom drain.
Then they began
spreading out the liner.
They hook the bead over
the top edge of the wall,
then lock it in place
with the top rail.
Once the liner is
fully attached,
they suction out the air to
draw it tight against the wall.
They seal the liner
to the bottom drain.
They hide the top
rail under the ledge,
and the connections
under plastic caps.
They run pipes to connect the
filtration system and skimmer.
Then, with an
ordinary garden hose,
they fill the pool with water.